[Music]  miss adams  you've certainly had a very interesting  educational journey  eight schools in five years  hey freak  this is a closed practice  the only person who gets to torture my  brother is me  [Music]  [Applause]  i did the world a favor  people like dalton shouldn't be allowed  to procreate  getting expelled was just a bonus  you will love nevermoor  it's a magical place where i met your  mother  finally you will be among peers who  understand you  maybe you'll even make some friends  i want to take a stab at being social  i do like stabbing  little did i know i'd be stepping into a  nightmare  full of mystery  mayhem  and murder  i think i'm going to love it here  you